Xbox ones it switches and you go to my
target your pricey no switches and a few
Xbox ones a penis wars you know I mean
according to it according to Adobe the
Nintendo switch won't Black Friday that
doesn't mean a whole lot it's just they
don't have all the data but alright
[Music]
welcome to the I Lord podcast episode
number 41 and it's another glorious
Sunday and we are back at the roundtable
on the Lord's Day we've got two very
special guests net neutrality Bungie
rigging the XP system Black Friday it's
switch third party to discuss so we're
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord whose content I first
came across through my good friends over
at brat podcast this Lord is one of the
most thought-provoking and passionate
members of our gaming community yet at
the same time respected by those who
actually matter in the industry while
some may be intimidated with the
intensity of his opinions this Lord is
always willing to engage in a civil
debate and Loki has some of the most
hilarious voice impersonations in the
game introducing the host of the
super-deformed games cast the former
Marine and protector of the filthy
neutrals aka welcoming into the realm of
the Lord's mana head sure
Lord John negative how are we doing sir
you know up until neutrals like he's not
talking about me you don't worry about
that is that that that turn Sam will
tell you that term was actually started
by a bunch of fanboys you know directed
of me yes so whenever you see the term
neutral on CH what Emma it's everywhere
now and I just I prefer the word normal
yes aka the normal yeah that was a help
an introduction that was that was
incredible thank you absolute pleasure
to have you here therefore that you
can't see I also um so I love it
but I do it's great to be here man I'm a
big fan of what you guys do and yeah I'm
ready to get into a man much appreciated
long overdue glad to have you and of
course we have a Lord who's always been
a friend to the round table this Lord is
one of the best young writers in the
game fellow tech geek was absolute
pleasure to finally meet in the flesh at
e3 2017 introducing the assistant editor
in chief and co-host of the real games
media podcast the direwolf an original
growth of Rivia finally making his
long-awaited ILP debut love it Lord
Samuel tobert are you doing sir I am
doing very well that was a great
introduction well done again you always
nailed the intros man it's it's good to
be here
I love what you guys do you're real you
keep it real let's just dive in start
queuing on these topics yeah absolutely
absolute pleasure man we got we got to
kick it by oh it was it via the Xbox
movie I think he was always super lucky
stale I remember that time yeah well
because we tried to meet if I remember
correctly by the sea of thieves booth
yes that one didn't work out so yeah the
interesting story there took a little
while we were running around each other
like chickens with our heads cut off
so we finally found each other Bobby
baby they shout up to the TV people we
love our GM good fans it up so we're
gonna of course we have the usual
suspects at the roundtable actually to
Lourdes down today where the Loretta's
definitely suffer from a big time
educate that man on benadryl to shut
these allergies now so I don't know he
might be out of commission at home Lord
soft he is actually vacationing man is
in in Dorne some way with lady saw
[Applause]
brother from another mother the
technical gaming Lord but of course we
have the excess gamer the Lord of combat
sports was a man of his convictions and
demands nothing less than the premium
experience Oh beloved Lord King are you
doing sir
what's going no we have a great show for
you today
let me give you a little bit of combat
sports this weekend let me tell you
something there's certain things that
I'm not feeling I'm not never feeling a
coward all right we had a surgery Koval
of which fought for Andre Ward's belts
that he ripped off his behind twice
listen Coppola for the cheeseburger last
night trust me I had ham and had all the
trimmings on it he was tearing it up he
had a turkey yesterday boxing it was HBO
crap you know I got a serves you up the
finest crap it was so it was so
hamburger II then I was like
I can't believe they trying to pass this
off as a fight anyway not to boil you
enough because I was bored enough for
you guys yesterday Sergey Kovalev
ate that hamburger two rounds he thinks
he's back he thinks he's you know um how
can I say it on top of the world
shout out to Andre Ward for trolling the
guy by showing up training videos of him
back in the ring and his whispers in the
world saying that he's back and he wants
to fight Koval off again you know just
roll these you know Audrey waters went
all the way up he's probably after Floyd
money Mayweather and bringing down
pound for pound the best fighter in the
world yeah so yeah and I love your boy
Conor McGregor right now he has the
world calling him out
Conor right now is a cash cow and he is
the best that the UFC has to offer
I love that system I mean that's pretty
much what it is I mean shoutout to Conor
I caught a little bit of UFC last night
I think all I cared about was Michael
Bisping going to sleep which he got
knocked out weeks ago he came in as a
replacement Dana put him as a head of a
cart at things at UFC Fight Night last
night and he got viciously put to sleep
so not only did he get choked out two or
three weeks before he's gotten put sleep
again and yeah his career might be over
so shot the [ __ ] being good warrior you
know but not a steroid era guys so we
got to respect it but yeah that Bell
might have called the old age wait for
know it a lot of sleep essential that's
right my boy is here let's go
my co-host with the cold mouse my
brother from another mother and the how
of the young wolf benadryl in the system
you will officially be lowered sleep
take like three just sleep the rest the
year looking too good to have the Lord
here so of course again Lord Cargill has
spread that game with us on Io
tell me what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so before we get into
what the Lord's are playing I want to
start off with a lot of negative this
video game system history and of course
what led him to the creation of the
amazing s DGC podcast Lord negative the
floor is yours
tell us about your history okay
I started in gaming with the you know
yes you know actually no that's
incorrect in television I don't know I
was like [ __ ] four years old in 1984
when my dad got mean in televisions I
don't have many memories of it but I do
remember I do remember in Utopia and
then of course you know I got the NES
and that kind of it kind of changed
everything and you know I went on to the
master system and then Genesis Super
Nintendo
I mean I've literally owned almost
almost every system almost every single
one I even had a Virtual Boy Wow
impressive
yeah the only virtual boy I had was
honesty and so yeah so now like I am I
don't own an Xbox one I have I have
everything right now except the next box
wants it but because I already played
games every day and there's a ton of
games to play and I just don't at the
time for a ps4 and a switch and a PC at
a 3ds and the Box one sorry I mistakenly
get labeled
as a PlayStation fanboy which is Sam
will tell you is hilarious because I
like fetch a lot better than the ps4 I
can tell oh yeah and you know that to me
is that to me is kind of than just the
defining characteristic of a fanboy you
knows that you are unable to there's a
difference between preference and bias
right like preferences can change you
know and right now I prefer the switch
you know earlier in this Jennifer for
the ps4 um I I started the the super fun
games cast because then of course super
deformed as a reference to the super
deformed characters of Super Nintendo
RPGs like Colin I was to ask you that
you broke that dad's I want to get a
whole science behind the name cool yeah
yes I've had a few people ask me like
you know you know what does that mean
and I'm like okay what beats this so I'm
glad that I'm glad that you would come
out of that um but I started that simply
because I just wanted a group to people
to talk games with um that's it and it's
now we now it's come to the point where
I was on a panel about about hatred in
the gaming community at PAX East we got
our we got our first league our media
credentials and it led to led to a lot
of friendships with people that I had
followed for a long time the gaming
industry which is so it's kind of
amazing to see it just a little just
started in my basement here and it was
it's kind of amazing to see what's
happened with it and how it's grown yeah
so yeah it's awesome I mean we're still
we're still small but then again I don't
want to be I don't want to be like you
know PewDiePie levels of because you
know we we've got a you got a we've got
a very very passionate localized
audience who comes into our chat every
week and there's no [ __ ] there's no
toxicity people just come in there and
they know that they will one get the
truth and two they won't get any fanboy
[ __ ] so I appreciate you man and um
at the end of the day like I said he
doesn't matter about the size about you
know what you're talking about and um
definitely respect that you know seeing
a lot of gay interviews I also want a
shout out on you you at home if it was
packs or a son gaming show and I had yes
and you had all one of the deaths from
blaster master zero which one of my
favorite sketch games really impressive
like master master was awesome we got to
interview him and we got to interview
the lead of for shovel knight and a
bunch of a bunch of other really cool
titles we got to talk to some people
from devolver which was really cool and
if you if you tune in to our show which
I'll give a shameless plug here which is
least not please pluck sir STG goes live
every Thursday night at 9 p.m. Eastern
we've had people just a few think it's
be bad on we've had on people from
Naughty Dog people from house mark
without on if you guys watch easy allies
we've had Kyle Kyle Boss Minh and my
Cuba Ron yes Jason Schreyer oh there's
an aren't Michael a little negative but
we had Mike Laidlaw who's who was the
creative director of Dragon Age yeah we
had a Mike Huber's gonna be on here
again in a few weeks he'll be his fifth
time on the podcast nice so yeah yeah we
yeah if if you guys want some good
gaming talk and no no [ __ ] so go
subscribe to our channel we'd appreciate
that much breezy and shadow also I want
to shout out to you guys uh Matt
piscatella is on your show line I like
to tune in for that when you guys do the
NPD also great stuff education I get to
learn a lot especially trends in the
industry and it's as far as how things
are selling and digital stuff so it's
really cool really appreciate what
you're doing out there
no doubt and of course lower Tolbert's
in the building his first time on the
show so a little recap of him a little
they started with his video games
history history you know young buck and
what led them over to real games media
okay well let's see if I can give a
really really condensed version really
quick then I started gaming pretty much
as soon as or maybe even before I could
walk and talk
I was playing Age of Empires I think for
at my fifth birthday I'm like a little
onslaught of its prepares salute to
those parents with my history few years
right very formula t'v that's probably
where I get my love of RTS games from
and I fell in love with Age of Empires
then it was civilization then it was
whatever free stuff I could run on
positions about [ __ ] right and then
civilization 2 was brutal that was no
joke even on the easier difficulties and
then my first console was an original
Xbox first game I ever played on was
battlefront 2 the original not be a
money hogging version loot box actual
landing inside of enemy ships and those
like the conquest it was great stuff
played that with my brothers then from
there of course yes it was heywho
republic commando the rest is history
playing battles these days is pretty
much playing the cliffnotes of the old
ones very shiny very shiny politics
delicious to me and so are GM let's see
it was about wait a minute it was
actually a year ago almost to this day
maybe a little bit more trying to
remember that i was in a party talking
with bella who's one of my really really
really good friends known each other for
a while now and i was talking about
being out of a job recently and that i
was looking to do something with writing
because i got beyond top marks and all
my english classes and she was like well
if you considered any sort of games
industry writing i was like yeah but
have you tried getting an internship
some of these places you're lucky if
they even throw a glance your way and
she's like hold that thought
give me a moment and i'll get back to
you on that day later I'm talking to
Julius as well who's another of the
co-founders at our GM start they start
me off I think writing one or two
articles every week just some very
low-level indie game reviews and before
I know it I'm at e3 jumping around
talking to developers like don't not
Entertainment one way in just a few
months it was it was crazy it was a
little surreal I'm still suffering a
little whiplash but it's awesome that we
met of course Lord kognito there dancing
I'm trying to find each other that was
great you know seeing all these
incredible developer
and publishers and everything they're
working on I've got to see a private
showing of days gone and some of the
stuff going on there it's it was
interesting you know and just I could
talk about all that all day but I've
gone a long way and I'm sure I've got a
long way to go but I'm loving with the
industry there is a lesson there is a
lesson here there's a lesson here and
and and this is the lesson both salmon
myself the reality is is we are we are
reasoned mature individuals who just
want to talk games I am I am a harsh
with my opinions but I am NOT cruel with
my opinion Sam is a very mature
reasonable individual who is
level-headed and speaks intelligently
and plainly and this is the reason that
developers and journalists engage with
us and not with others absolutions of
the fan base stay so please
I'm the equivalent to you to this
podcast and Sam's the equivalent to
kognito of that boys from every side of
the from every walk of life you know
from whatever no matter what concert
there why doesn't so and so engage with
me and why isn't so why does someone get
this is why mm-hmm this is why people
people want to have especially people in
the industry once you have intelligent
conversations not they don't want to
shout at each other so so if you want to
get recognized by people that you are
fans of in the industry be kind because
I mean I valid points in it I think you
just nailed it little negative I mean
that's why I like I said here the iron
law podcast we definitely try to promote
that atmosphere you know when it'd be
kinda chaw they're gonna respect each
other you know we keep the language to a
minimum you know we don't want to offend
too many people but we're gonna have fun
and have a good time and yeah I was I'm
gonna do my best to talk it back
I was also a marine I know and I I every
is fifth word that comes out of my mouth
is just work so I'm gonna do my best man
no little back tip I respect you and I
know the effort is there that's all I
get for a reason to get busy so we don't
shout out to a reason that ncgc goes
live at 9:00 it's the docile god looks
like we got a man in the buildings for
breath gentlemen what is going on oh I
just wanna stay in the pleasure and lord
King I have upgraded my friend what you
did when I've got a 4k TV yesterday okay
you bought that because you wanted it
not because he suggested whoa timeout
timeout
I don't care why you brought it see
there you go that's my man right there
he went out and he upgraded wait is that
Eric he's up he's you were the person
has knocked out like this I got back I'm
happy Jonel joking aside I drove by
Walmart and I immediately thought of
your impersonation just want to get this
benadryl right now I know hot monkeys
love is in church I know you was gonna
listen right now shout out the hot
monkeys loving now boy David Rodriguez
for picking up this de Sam Sun q9s I
went with David actually to the store to
pick up his and monkey was recommended
the television shout-out to you guys for
going out to get it and also shout out
to
oh man I'm gonna get his name again
everybody out here that's doing the
thing I really appreciate your cane TV
movement Lord rap what did you pick up
on the 4k front just so you know so I
just I I went budget this time okay I
went the TCL smoke I got a lot of
recognitions from people who've picked
it up or read about it I did my homework
on it I mean it's uh it's got some good
reviews and yeah it's uh is it all set
up or is the HDR gloriousness the the in
low input lag that 4k resolution is it
all set up it is and I can't stop
playing Assassin's Creed now I agree
with you 100% the combats not the
greatest but yeah yeah I'm actually the
agreement today so that's cool so we got
the Lords in the food we got a full
house now and uh want to get into really
quickly just a brief I know it's been a
Black Friday everything and holidays
eating and good times but it any of the
laws get a chance to play anything so
let's start with a lot of negative Oh
what have you been playing this week oh
okay
so I played about 10 hours of Assassin's
Creed but that combat is just so clunky
doesn't it like it does but again salmon
and Rika will tell you I'm a I'm a Dark
Souls purist so I I'm a I'm a Souls guy
so you know if there is a if there a
soul similar comment a game I'm gonna
hold it up to Dark Souls and blood-borne
and most games just can't handle that so
I have been playing firing the warriors
and about 20 hours and then I what else
am I playing I I have finished so many
games this year it's unbelievable
I'm actually playing I'm actually right
now I'm not playing anything that I
bought on by Friday I'm replaying
Valkyria Chronicles on ps4
nice though and I love up here if you
never played Valkyria Chronicles and
you're
a real-time strategy or or stress RS
RPGs but Kira Chronicles is a fantastic
game and then I am I'm juggling I'm
gonna pick up axiom verge multiverse
edition on switch I played your ex
members like 15 billion times I'm trying
so hard not to swear right now we love
you I am juggling and that is the that
is what the beauty in the curse of 2017
is that there are so many great games
that have come out here it is almost
impossible to I mean I just in October I
finished Depot with into Wolfenstein 2
destiny - I mean there's it's
unbelievable how many good games are and
then of course in a week we have
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 comes out and
that will be able to forgive my December
probably Sam what have you been playing
this week oh good lord
okay so I hadn't been playing quite as
much as I would have liked to simply
because I'm in finals prep right now so
crunch time time is limited but I did
make a little raid on the Xbox Black
Friday sales I got both the evil within
games and then I got dishonor to and
dishonor death of the outsider so I've
been chewing into those right now so I'm
gonna drive yeah yeah and I'm gonna try
and get a review of the evil within two
up no promises
sometimes maybe this week when I
finished that when I'm loving the first
one right now though let's made to
chapter fantastic good combat very
excellent enemy design Sebastian may be
the dullest survival horror protagonist
either Sebastian maybe yeah like I love
Sebastian's reactions like in the first
people within like something horrific
will happen and he'll say like right six
arms you know stringy hair ghost girl
chasing after he's like something's
wrong with this place yeah no kidding
like there could be there could be like
a corpse growing out of another corpse
chasing them down a hallway and easily
there's something seriously wrong with
this know it I say that but like the
like I just wanted this is a scene that
almost nobody will see the evil with
incredibly well hidden but there's one
scene you've got to go like there's like
30 minutes of backtracking to get to it
this is just to get to Sam's point but
these guys know how to put humor in
their games too there's a scene like you
go back to O'Neill and and he says I'm
not going out there there's it's evil
out there and then Sebastian says yeah
but there's evil within - and then they
break the fourth wall and they both look
at the player like this no yes I've been
digging my teeth into those I'm really
looking forward to getting to the second
one because I'm a huge fan of survival
horror I'm also loving Dishonored - it's
everything I loved about the first one
and then it's perfected arcane are some
of the best level designers I'm aware of
they know how to make players want to
use their powers want to explore they
know how to make a good movement system
so yeah it's I could sing the praises of
that game all day I've also been playing
quite a bit of total war Warhammer -
because the mortal empires update just
came out so that's been a lot of fun you
see thousands upon thousands of mythical
soldiers blasting each other to pieces
it's good for stress relief you know
yeah what anchorman in the chat has how
how old is this this Lord Sam guy he
said is he a young buck of the Lord's
Lord Lord visit yeah he's got to be the
statement from the court later on yeah
those are the major games I've been
playing right now I also have been I
recently got thousand of a thousand in
shadow of war really enjoyed that as a
premium game on the X like you can play
it on any other console on
even you know ps4 Pro and then played on
the X and you can tell where the work
was really put it and the best thing
about it yeah yeah it's good the combat
is great I love it there's some
interesting story twists in the third
act had a lot of fun with that have also
been suffering through cuphead no no I'm
having a lot of fun don't get me wrong
it's a blast it's just if you don't get
the patterns down these bosses are I've
only got a couple left I think based off
of where I am so far so and that's
pretty much I'm gonna mall in one sip
1:30 going it's always a party are they
heading our cookies are they hitting
that out neck is very sparkling right
now always good to have most technical
gaming Lord you got you got the Cokie
ahead what's going on in a little while
don't worry about that okay we glad to
have you this is a little crazy over
here so I don't want it I just want to
dump and say what's up to the guys no
yeah so where we talk about right now
what was the topic just doing it we got
we got wrapping to build up with the
Lords of plain and touch that net
neutrality we go touch
mr. negative brat wealth is on today
I'll put my two cents in real quick on
that neutrality a Gamestop is probably
really happy I think all of those
physical sales are gonna start
skyrocketing when people can't pay pay
for internet so jumped in on the digital
Andy I mean it's gonna cost if that
happens it's very very scary times as
much as a you know a lot of us fighting
fight for loot boxes and
microtransactions this is probably one
of the most scary things that could
possibly affect gamers so just something
that we definitely want to bring to the
light and speak speaking of which Oh
Lord saw we had last week's poll that
was up and the question was with the
removal of microtransactions from our
Star Wars Battlefront to EA has stated
that they will return in the future and
changes are made to the game is this
acceptable so the winner at 58% in a
very emotional poll was the No keep
those damn microtransaction I think
they've been the ones that have been
most egregious about how they implement
them I think Activision if you look at
Call of Duty and even if you look at the
sneaky stuff they did with destiny like
in terms of like progression and stuff
like that in XP if they're trying to
figure out sneaky ways of getting it
around the game where it's just the
truth about it like it's not something
it's something you got to try to hide as
best you can and EA has not been good
about that everybody like you know what
this is what it is and you got a hold
that and and you know people spoke with
their wallets and it's not going down so
I don't think it's for that game in
particular you don't bring that back
yeah so coming yeah coming in at second
place
32% was the yes group it's a micro
transaction was way overblown and at
third place in shallow 10% no shallow
10% guys they said when can they get
there
premium video though we could get it to
the heart of it you know you'll get a
heart of these topics and I get soft
along with gotcha but you go really top
I'm glad I'm glad you said enjoy enjoy
stay safe love you brother
love you bro absolutely soundly and soft
too so um yeah so pretty much we can
dive into the meat of it um we're gonna
really get no Charlie hard so um
obviously this is a you know a hot topic
right now and you know something I
wanted to bring to the round table
because I don't really feel it's getting
enough you know light and shout the brat
for coming through because let me tell
you man brap killed it one of his ladies
ranch off yeah I haven't been paying
attention checkout wraps latest rent
regarding net neutrality and you know
for those living under a rock you know
let me try basically the principle that
you know all internet is PS you know
they must treat their data and not
discriminate as far as the internet
content website and stuff that
everything kind of gets you know
addressed freely so under those
principles you know no one will be able
to throttle block or slow down specific
websites or online content so as we know
this coming in December is um it's
pretty much is in jeopardy of being
threatened and I know the here we at the
ILP we try not to get too political you
know we respect everyone everyone's got
their different views but as far as
gaming I felt this was something that we
should talk about and I'm at the end of
the day is something that does affect
gamers so I'm gonna actually start off
with Lord negative first because I got
brat I'm gonna get rapping cuz he's he's
the expert he's one of the leaders of
the movement but I wanna stop negative
first and what do you feel about what's
going on you know and your input on this
whole new net neutrality well first of
all just want to say there's 3-1 people
watching this right now and only 20
likes oh come on guys yes please
I am not convinced that this repeal of
net neutrality is actually gonna happen
oh it has been let's just say a long
time since I have seen anything so
roundly condemned
by every you know everybody I almost had
the effort there by I had to stop myself
it has been it has been years since I've
seen something so roundly condemned by
everybody and interestingly enough in a
year or 2017 where people are so divided
in this country you know between the
right and the left like this is the one
thing that seems to be bringing
everybody together is their their their
mutual disdain and and unhappiness about
the repeal of net neutrality and let's
face it if net neutrality goes away I
mean that's bad for everybody I mean and
people don't really understand what that
means you know so if you don't know what
net neutrality is basically you can you
know this is what keeps this is the this
is the First Amendment of the internet
basically um it is it protects our
rights but it keeps companies
conglomerates like Comcast for example
we all know how bad Comcast is oh heas
Comcast for example from reducing the
bandwidth force for your Netflix in
order to promote their own streaming
service home with net neutrality Gunn
Comcast for example can charge you your
ISP more to access one web site as
opposed to another they can block
websites completely on a whim if they
want to and there's absolutely nothing
you can do about any of this and calm
cat companies on Comcast are already bad
enough they've already got more than
enough power because in many swaths of
the country like mine they're the sole
they are the sole option you have for
for internet and cable services so
dealing with these people are it's
already bad enough but if net neutrality
goes away I mean honestly I mean these
companies not enough these these
companies but you know as like companies
like Verizon and and you know cell phone
companies they can charge whatever they
want for internet whatever they want for
internet access there is no there's no
flat rate anymore that's that's gone um
and I am Not sure I am not convinced
that it's actually gonna happen because
it is so roundly unpopular and
if it does happen there will be there
will be a blowback like you have never
seen exactly exactly yeah I hope you're
right man because I don't buy into I
mean that might just be the that might
just be what you know what what little
hope I have left we should take in 2017
you've taken every please don't take
this don't let it end like this
the party the party go ahead the part
that kills me about this whole net
neutrality thing is like I don't
understand how a situation is being
brought back up that you have these ISPs
like saying they you know like the only
definition to not do it is oh we won't
do we problem it's like I don't
this is being brought up like why is
this even an issue II like you know
money people that's what I'm saying you
might people are putting some serious
money behind this to get this if people
are putting up this kind of money to
even have this brought up it's with bad
intentions I hate to interject let
Eggman has a question for Lord King he
said that this should be issue with you
like king will pegs more for premium
it's a bit 1% but let me explain how it
is a issue for all when a net neutrality
was first imposed and Obama I don't want
to get into the whole political but when
he championed that and that was signed
and that was put in that was a safeguard
against what was going to happen and
what was happening you know the
practices that were what's happening if
you notice that um you started getting
lower our cellphone bills they had to
like do this whole unlimited thing and
you know it got a little bit better as
far as your wallet went um and yeah good
it pretty much like made like all the
other you know your power bill all these
people have to follow a guideline and
all
all net neutrality did is it made them
follow Internet as the same guideline
right it made everybody play nice now um
when it comes to your wallet and this is
what I my fear is okay everybody's oh
and we should be afraid for the video
games right physical as well as digital
alright um so the fair is in the digital
realm but my fear is back to the cell
phones once it gets to the point where
they say okay well the strengthened
restraints is off of us then we can go
back to these crazy prices when you were
paying you know $400 for two cell phones
before remember that was a reality
before now your bills have lowered they
will skyrocket right back up because
they will be able to enforce a certain
bandwidth on you and when scary tears
tear this brat with the dude bro tier
Mike might show up possibly people that
have contracts like those contracts will
expire of insulin you like yeah just
because you sign in to a fixed price
don't mean that contract won't last the
rest of your life like I don't want to
understate the danger of of taking that
neutrality away but at the same time I
also think there's a danger overstating
what will happen do I think it's the end
of the Internet as we know it do I think
it's the do I think it's the internet
apocalypse no probably not
um my concern is just one giving these
giving these one or two entities
even more power than they already have
over yes and and and to I mean you know
look for the middle class it's probably
gonna be fine for the for the you know
for the for the people who don't make as
much money some other people do it's
going to be a problem and and you know
and so that is my concern I am more
concerned about people who who are not
as fortunate down to it you know there's
a lot of these people that you know they
still have when it comes to consumer
friendly they still like to be consumer
friendly but a lot of these companies
they're not the majority they're
not the Comcast they're not the horizons
these companies are going to find anyway
and you know we can't say for a hundred
percent who these companies are going to
do austerity but it's like these
companies haven't done anything in the
past ten years to chose that they
wouldn't those dirty and say what though
I'll tell what though --if net
neutrality goes away this is a golden
opportunity for some small service
provider to be like hey we're not gonna
charge we're not gonna do any of this
junk right be the doubles champions
exactly and and and so you know there's
a you know there's a sunny spot to every
you know you know at every storm cloud
but you know I don't know maybe that's
just that's just the the hopeful we're
gonna be coming out again I want to get
a lord Sam one there's only get his
viewpoint before passing over the love
breath everything that has been said
here you know it's been said and it's
been said more eloquently than I can put
it on a dime's knows I will say this the
fact is you don't it's easy to see the
intent of many of these major
conglomerates and companies when they're
saying we're not going to change
anything we're still committed providing
at the exact same way it's like saying
okay we don't intend to murder anybody
we go good oh no no that that wall needs
to go away
we murder anybody no it doesn't make any
sense the very fact that you want to go
away it all shows what in struggle the
moment a law is being looked at to be
overturning that is anti consumer you
know you know it's it's not a good thing
it's it's like I said earlier it's got
clear bad intentions there's no way
around it it's got clear bad intentions
regardless it's like the gaming industry
you you let them get away with a little
bit they keep inching their way back up
the habitual and stepping the biggest
issue for me at least is the fact that I
think John pointed this out as well
these companies are so close to
monopolies or duopoly yes it's legal
they've made arrangements with the
United States government over here I
don't know how it is another you know
countries like they have legit
monopolies
they are completely legal because they
have completely separated the entire
country districts I mean anytime the FCC
comes out and says well here's the
reason we're doing this book me the only
the only response you need and the
reason that you know this isn't this is
insidious is just ask the question why
why get rid of it exactly why not leave
it as is not harming anything and you
don't intend to change it why does it
need to go exactly and the other thing
that I don't think is also getting
pointed out is that you know you know
the the if you want to play devil's
advocate and you say okay well if it
goes through what's the big deal you
know open market you know that kind of
bit you know there's a lot of areas
where people don't necessarily have
another good competition far from an isp
perspective to switch to exactly a week
so yeah I know but I'm just gonna speak
from myself when I first moved from you
know New York to Jersey City and when I
was stuck with Comcast like I was trying
to get out of that there was no other
competitive ISP that I could switch to
so I was kind of like for us the men
that they will until that kind of came
about and even so then that was still
kind of hard so there's a lot of people
in those situations where they really
can't switch you know you know the lines
are kind of controlled by a bigger
entity you know kind of thing so you got
my area Comcast is gonna be the only
provider for anytime soon yeah you know
Google you know they're not coming
around here for the most part they've
slowed up on their production they still
build but you know they're not coming to
a little area like mine Verizon they're
here but they don't have their you know
their BIOS or anything here so you know
they're mainly just a cellphone provider
here but uh you know Comcast is it it's
all the arts it they all be all in the
funny part about that whole scenario is
I'm pretty sure the reason that you know
Comcast is the only person here is
because probably Comcast is paid to be
the only person here yeah and this is
it's like one of those things like you
said you know like it's just like you
know if you're upset with Comcast we're
realistically can you go right like
where kid exactly where's this
competitive market it you know we don't
go to dish exactly so I want to get
lured rapping
cuz uh he is the man right now like he
did my father it was the most beautiful
eloquent vengeance and I really don't
think you get enough credit for actually
spearheading that movement making game
was aware stop fighting over foolishness
fanboy stuff you know who system is
better let's talk about what's important
so a little brat before is just talk to
us about this net neutrality thing yeah
no you know I I've been very outspoken
about this because I've seen people
argue over I'm seeing it with Black
Friday sales now seeing it you know with
over plastic boxes over resolution and
I'm like you know guys this is you know
take all that negative energy and
channel it towards something positive
like this like pay attention and I and I
said this in my podcast I said there's
this there's no coincidence that this
vote is taking place December 14th yep
talk about that mm-hmm
because everyone everyone right now is
focused on shopping trying to holidays
we're driving all day yeah we're
distracted soda I think the last one was
took around this place - Oh was it I
think what it was enforced it was took
around this time - okay wait but I'm not
surprised I mean I'm not surprised
they're doing this at this time of year
and that's why we have to pay attention
to what's going on because like everyone
has said on this podcast and and I agree
T John I don't think it's the death of
the internet or you know this is the
internet apocalypse but I do think this
is gonna have a negative impact not just
on consumers but on possible Internet
start-ups yeah you know look a Comcast
goes out on Twitter and I hammer them
because they're like oh we're not gonna
throttle India what I'm like if you have
to come out and say it was a so strongly
then yeah you probably will yeah exactly
they already had they've already have
yeah they did it in Netflix in 2014
Netflix how to pay Comcast Munt extra
money the some of them the amount wasn't
ever disclosed I just feel like that
should be illegal
like that's blackmail pretty much
right now insulation is the regulation
yeah it's blackly it doesn't make it
makes blackmail legal in the funny thing
about it is when you look at it from a
perspective you know people were just
looking at from like you know the
Internet provider perspective it goes
bigger than that let's say that you know
Comcast is is being hit up by Sony was
like we don't like Microsoft what slow
put them in the slow lane and Microsoft
gotta pay some money to get in that fast
lane again guess who guess who they're
gonna put that cost to taking it they're
gonna they're gonna increase the cost of
Xbox Live or increase the cost of game
pass something to accommodate that money
they just dished out to Comcast yeah and
your Verizon do the same thing to
Netflix they throttle them and Netflix
how to pay Verizon so these companies
look and they try to do this back in
2005 AT&T some other telecom and cable
companies got together and they try to
create toll lanes like fast lanes mm-hm
2011 Verizon t-mobile and I think AT&T
they partner we discovered to create a a
wallet app for their phones and at that
point Google already released Google
Wallet Verizon actually blocked the
Google Wallet app yes we're trying to do
their own compete competing thing
correct exactly so these companies have
a history of doing this which is why
it's so important for us to seriously I
already I've called my local Congress
represented by congressmen voicing my
you know my displeasure against the
possible you know then possibly
overturning net neutrality I mean I'm
just I'm telling everyone just do it
just it just takes a quick phone call
there's a couple websites after I don't
remember them off the top my head yeah
you can go to as well some petition
sites and then yeah I'll put that up put
the links in the description in the show
because again it's one of those things
that again like we gamers we tend to
galvanize over all these other things
and you know just you know we understand
a Star Wars loot box thing we get it you
know we understand micro transactions we
get it but the way
look at it you know you know in the
north rap you made some great points is
just like especially this this error of
4k gaming and the xbox one acts and huge
downloads think about forget about you
in 4k like if you just think about the
size of games right now
think about you know having that
throttled and data caps and stuff like
that and being forced into a potential
here add it to your bill per month if
you want to continue doing what you've
already been doing it's one of those
things again you know I agree with more
negative no I don't want to like fear
monger and I don't want to like you know
oh my god it's the end of the world no
you know saying business will go on
things will have to still continue but
there might be changes that affect you
as a game and this is something that we
definitely need to bring the light and I
really appreciate what SDG seeing and
rapid doing with this because you know
this is the things we need to be talking
about right like things that need to be
put a light on and stop focusing on
foolishness and the other thing the
other two thing I was gonna say is that
you got to remember something these
companies like Verizon Comcast our media
companies - Comcast owns NBC yes
Verizon owns media Verizon owns Yahoo
they own the Huffington Post yes they
bought all of a oels media companies
that a o.l own Verizon bought those so
we have to think about that and think
about the implies are gonna obviously
push the companies they own because they
want to make money at the end of the day
you know people see people on Twitter
saying you can't really say the world's
gonna end just because I like you can't
but at the end of the day it's like you
know we can't it's not our job to you
know enforce anything on these companies
we are consumers and we can do anything
we want when it comes to if anyone's
gonna screw us when it comes to that the
promise is the problem is that 90% of
consumers don't care yeah facts you're
right that's why that's why I mean
that's why we have loot boxes that's why
we have microtransactions these things
are there because because people pay for
them and we can scream and holler on
social media all day about vote with
your wallet vote with your wallet but
the simple truth is that 90% of this is
just an example 90% of the gaming of
gaming consumers or casual gamers who
are not on social media and and don't
I don't have time and have money to burn
um which is that's why I loo trick
that's why this stuff is here and that's
why that's my net neutrality is a danger
of going waste because people are either
uninformed or or they just don't care
and they don't care they say okay well
I'll pay a few those we really like
blame you know that the customers these
days because like when it comes down to
it there's a good amount of casuals that
was born into this into this stuff like
they don't know anything different they
they they've been around with the loot
boxes when they started gaming when
they're 13 14 loot boxes as well in its
way already and that's all they know mmm
you're saying before everything was
shipped on disc now you're able to
capitalize on the Internet as far as
micro transactions go I mean I'm I'm an
egregious a habitual line step or when
it comes to it I was just in Assassin's
Creed this week and trust me
I play to when I pay to win I'm gonna be
in that store to get it is a gift and a
curse but I don't want it to be forced
upon us you know I have a choice I make
a choice I don't want to lauric when do
in in Las Vegas he has a data cap right
so he pays a certain amount of money for
X amount of data and for more data you
have to pay $10 or $20 more now I know
for a fact that his will go up as soon
as this law is abolished hmm all right
they're gonna be like well remove it at
20 to $10 it is $25 now protein hoist
labrat beautifully
it's not fear mongering it's making
people aware and a lot of people in
active on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook we are the voices for those
people who aren't aware because I spoke
to a couple of people I had no idea they
were doing this no I dear people that
have no idea what's going on it's like
la Brive said again
it's like the beef for the night the
catcher does movie fat and happy like no
absolutely talking truth out here and
you know what screw you it's crazy
that's Wednesday one more thing about
this there's there's 22 million unique
comments the FCC about this majority
those comments are against the FCC
overturning net neutrality the FCC has
even read or even brought this up
there's this much like outcry against
them overturning net neutrality which is
really interesting considering that
there is a I mean despite like you know
I've talked to people and because
they're not we talk to people who aren't
aware of it but there is a I think a
considerable amount of people that are
against this I mean the media is
covering it now there's been a lot of
articles about this so I I see this
thing gaining traction that's why and
that's why I'm not convinced it's
actually gonna happen
Lord negative I really hope so man I
hope you giving me hope man I really
hope so I really hope people are paying
attention because this is something that
it's important and especially as gamers
and this is a gaming platform it affects
us so good stuff good stuff Lords this
is real good move one if anyone has
anything else left exhaust on net
neutrality get your shots get your
drinks ready because good friends over
Bungie as you know I love podcasts
originally started as a destiny only
podcast and unfortunately our good
friends got the hand caught in the
cookie jar
reddit user definitely did some
algorithm work and found out that they
were secretly throttling and reducing XP
gains and so those who don't know when
you play destined to and get to level 20
in each max cap as you continue to do
activities you continue to level and
that bar then gives you this thing
called the bright Engram the bright
Engram usually consists of a lot of
things mods cosmetic stuff emotes
there's so many things that this thing
can happen it can actually consist of
but it also is something that you can
easily buy from the ever verse door
which is regular transactions in its
finest you can go over there you know
for smooth five ten bucks and purchase
yourself some silver and get you those
things that you desire that haven't been
coming in R and G so as this was a
brought to the attention um ready it
went pretty viral pretty fast and a lot
of the big people in the community who
actually support the game shadow I want
a shout out to people that I'm really
good friends with a friend Marabella he
was on it tugging tugging about a couple
guys from IGN about great relationships
with you know and they jumped on it
immediately and um pretty much you know
just want to say pay to win but
influencing microtransaction by
throttling your ability to grind the
game so as we found out you know
literally a day later
um Bungie released a statement and it
was a kinda out of character cuz it
wasn't a there's a big weekly Bungie
update that they usually do they
actually created a statement like
immediately in response to the backlash
they were receiving and pretty much said
that they are going to outline changes
this is gonna be stopped immediately
this the algorithm that was in place and
then next week they're gonna detail some
some changes to community feedback and
stuff like that so I want to bring this
to the round table
now that bungees been caught the hand
corner cookie jar as far as this XP game
- what do we think about it and since
Lord negative you sound like you got
some hot takes let's start so I play a
lot of destiny I played a lot of the
first destiny and I play a lot of
destiny - while I agree that it's it's a
scummy practice
I don't I don't think this is the I
don't think this is the big deal that a
lot of people think it is for several
reasons one look I I guarantee you that
yeah it's hilarious that they got caught
and their statement was beyond beyond
hilarious like all guys were so sorry we
had no idea you know but you know like
at the same time and guarantee you like
if you think for one second that there
is not a game out there with
microtransactions it does not have a
similar system in place that has not
found yet come on so so this is not
let's you know this is not unique to
Bungie they just got caught - like I
would have a much bigger problem with
this if the ever vers had and if like
you know the ever verse trading store
had anything other than like meaningless
skins and ships that are do nothing or
shaders you know so I'm like okay like
yeah it's lame but whatever I mean there
there are other things I would rather
Bungie focus on a destiny to does so so
you know people you know people can
people can you know scream to the
heavens and said you know like I can't
believe you were trying to get me to buy
shaders you know you know like if there
were if there were like amazing exotic
weapons in the ever verse that that you
know unbalanced like I feel like the
battlefront to stuff was a much bigger
deal and the unlike and of course you
know the common thread that binds both
of these issues together is people
raised people gamers raised their voices
about it and both they think both these
things were changed so in a way I feel
this this is a positive situation
because it proves that gamers have a
voice and and people are finally
starting to listen to them to the
problems that gamers have with you know
we know what these practices and
I am going to reserve judgment on the
situation until next Wednesday and we
get some more input as to what they're
gonna do with the end to improve the end
game and you know the loot system and
the progression system that is what I am
more concerned about amen honestly to
like yeah like you know people really
it's lame it's a lame practice you know
whatever I thought battlefront 2 was
much more egregious and I'm gonna use
that word too and look like I just yeah
they got caught in it's hilarious Taemin
was hilarious but at the end of the day
I'm just like I I expect this of big
companies this oh I'm like okay whatever
no you jump on this next and offer the
counterpoint go for it okay I agree with
you John it wasn't an issue right now
it's not an issue right now the loot and
the progression is destiny to as much as
I love as much as the fun I've had with
the endless hours I poured into it it
has a big end game content problem right
now but who says this wouldn't have been
an issue one expansion down the line or
maybe the one after that or the ones
that were definitely two is explicitly
hang on destiny to is explicitly being
built I don't think this is too much of
a reach as a game that is going to
endure for at least some years or at
least some time they want players to
come back for the new content they want
them to come back for the next raid
you know yet curse of Osiris coming up
and then whatever comes on after that I
presume it's gonna follow a similar
model to the first destiny I don't know
maybe it will we'll see maybe not the
point is they're relying on those
recurring players not the casual
audience per se and those those veteran
players are already pouring in so many
dozens and hundreds of hours it gets
harder and harder to level up well then
what happens when the level cap gets
raised and then it gets raised again and
it gets even more frustrating to level
up I'm not saying it's an issue right
now but I guarantee it would have been
issued way down the line but but when
you're but when you hit the when you hit
the cap and you're talking about
leveling up I mean you're talking about
getting shaders you're you're talking
about getting you know a a chance at a
weapon ornament that for a weapon you
may not even
right now lucky that it's the case right
now but yeah I don't know like I feel
like you I feel like that is putting the
cart before the horse and and and you
know I mean regardless I mean the system
is done like because people are going to
be watching at my Hawk now so so so like
the whole point my opinion is moved on
because people are gonna be looking at
this now with three different pairs of
binoculars and let that algorithm
expansion my people go I just I don't
know maybe I'm reading a little too much
into it maybe I'm being a little too
cynical 2017 has had very gating effect
on me but the fact that destiny to as
great a game it is has such incredible
endgame content problems and yet in
place destiny one as much as I loved it
head and game problems I mean you know
so I mean this seems to be I said on
Twitter the other day and people people
took this the wrong way on Twitter the
other day I said I said Destiny's
biggest hurdle is Bungie yeah
and when people said oh this you know
and people you know and granted I should
have been a little more you know
explanatory about what I meant but I I
don't mean that the game is Matt I love
destiny what I mean is that there has
been absolutely no feedback from the I
mean this is the first time we've really
gotten a response to criticisms from
Bungie and it's and it's over something
that they got caught doing they're not
address it's every other week these guys
are stripping on their own feet and I
said like because I didn't understand
what they were saying it
I don't know I know a lot of you who
play destiny too and oh and none of them
buy silver from the store so I'm like
okay who cares like I mean yeah they
were yeah it is it's coming sure
whatever but was it really affecting you
in the long run not at all really
Oh Bungie you know Bungie was you know
their sorcery man they're trying and I
hear what you go with Lamech well I just
want to jump in real quick you're
totally right if anyone who plays
destiny knows what bright engrams you
know they're not really game-changing
you know Peter witness there's really
nothing that's going to affect gameplay
in that regard but I do hear what Laura
Salmons coming from but the thing I want
to get to is just like what I'm
personally upset with is that like you
said the issues with DES t2 right now
rely in the end game right people feel
it's either over casualized there's not
enough stuff to do and the thing right
now is where everyone was waiting for
transparency and feedback from this
community managers to say hey when are
you fixing the end game so that's it was
kind of funny that they got caught with
this and it immediately came out with a
statement to say okay we're doing this
we're doing that we're doing this that
we're doing that when meanwhile the
community has been begging them when are
you going to talk about this end game
that we're upset with like I think I
think a lot of the anger over the over
the everywhere stuff is just a residue
from people being frustrated about
Bungie not communicating about what they
get go because I know like when I get a
bright and grand pop up life like you
know when when my little yellow bar
fills up and again it says you've got a
bright and grim my excitement level
registers exactly the same as like when
I learned oh we have a breakfast is a
bold plain oatmeal yeah yeah like if my
wife were to tell me hey what we've got
for breakfast today is plain oatmeal and
my reaction is okay whatever
that's that's what happens when I see a
bright and grand Papa I'm like oh it's
the plain oatmeal of gaming so so if
you're really upset that I mean if you
are super duper upset you feel Bungie
was forcing you to bite bright and
Graham's like okay whatever like yeah
again yes it's a scummy practice but
they're just bright and grim so just I
take all that energy that you have about
being upset about the oatmeal of video
games and put that into put that into
the nether actually having Bungie
effective change in the game itself
because it needs it the game has bigger
problems than bright and Graham's oh
absolutely
as we look braaap I want to get to you
know this that at the the hand was
slapped got a question first before our
Lord Brian goes go ahead on the raid yet
Lord breath no that's on the raid I'm
waiting for you guys I think I reach out
to addict I'm like hey let's do the raid
this weekend he's like nah we're we're
both we're boycotting destiny right now
you reached out to the wrong person de
loarre Brett we got you if we do we're
gonna against my wishes and my beliefs
you know I think everyone's made some
really good points here I think I think
Sam what you were going with is like
this thing could have potentially gotten
worse if I understand that correctly
yeah it's not dude it's an issue right
now it's this guy again maybe I'm too
cynical but you have an endgame content
problem but yet you're throttling XP
what does that mean two or three
expansions and I kind of agree with that
too like what what it and I'm glad that
like I'm glad like that that they got
exposed per se because this thing could
have gone this thing could have gone out
of control everybody else heard that
noise
was it a bit cocaine I just decided to
ignore it it sound like some was blowing
balloons or something I turn a rat
it sounded like it's not like a chicken
just did a line of cocaine I do have
concerns with these games that focus on
player engagement like this stuff is
something that we and I'm glad the
community spoke out against it I think
big picture this is something that we we
have to be aware of we have to because I
think like you're saying saying like
this it may not it may not happen in
destiny yeah but could happen another
game where you know this could impact
you actually getting the kind of weapons
you honor the weapons you would use you
know and those things to me are things
that worried me as a consumer that you
know these developers are taking
advantage of people's time and money and
doing things that necessarily aren't in
the best interest of the consumer so
Yanis lord brat like based on the
content problem right now right lack of
endgame yep not interesting that that
was throttled right because they they're
basically an essentially wants you to
grind more to get said bright engrams
matter regardless how lame they are
right there's really not enough to do so
I guess when you do a public event like
that we'll use like savory farming
public events and destiny right now is
probably the easiest activity they don't
try to to gain experience and you see
that kind of throttle down to about 5%
it's kind of showing to me almost
screams like they don't have enough
content no they don't that's why they
were watching the this is our most
rewarding public I was done I was I
wasn't worth watching that and like I
had to shut my office door and just cry
that was pre-recorded like wha it was a
low point it was a definitely a low
voice oh good do you love rap now get
out
finish this thing no best to take this
foot I think I can see part of the
community being outrageous because of
the end game issues yeah you know it's
like wait we haven't heard anything from
the for the Community Managers and now
we've caught them doing something shady
and but now they're engaged with us Lord
at the bells in okay first off when it
comes to the micro transaction I don't
give a [ __ ] about that but uh I don't
want to go in on this end game I think I
think I just couldn't have to say that
it was sleazy what they did with the
whole micro transaction and lying to us
I'm not gonna go in the end game the end
game problems because we all don't have
time for that so me and you will save
that after stream three because I really
want to hold off on this topic to LA I
mean you've been we've been chomping at
the bit we've been ready to unleash but
we like less wait until we see all the
streams right and then we'll kind of
talk about but then this kind of
happened we like okay we gotta kind of
talk about every stream they do it I
usually catch streams live but I've been
so like I don't care anymore with this
company that I'm just like IGN will tell
me what happened watching that like you
know the the what's the word I'm looking
for the the recaps of these are streams
and and you cast lor Cognito like the
moment i saw that that raid lair
quote-unquote I was like I was straight
to Twitter and I just put I just put one
phrase destiny to install I'm such a
huge ray person I'm not gonna go all out
on this I'm gonna wait give me nothing
I bought the the expansions I'm not
gonna be like one of these people and
just completely boycott the game I did
buy the expansions I fell for it I got
finesse so I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna hold I'm gonna try their
confident I'm gonna see how this raid
layer is because any anyone in you know
iron loss podcast channel 5 they will
tell you that like my bread and butter
in this game is right if they get the
raids again because I personally feel
like the raid the Leviathan was fun but
it was get compared to the original you
sound like you're not excited about
apartment to see great it's a great
concept like came up to the table and he
were putting this he was putting it out
for bungie
because you know if it feels like the
rain is done on a budget right it's big
enough they never tell you this ship is
huge enough that it eats planets right
so there's no possible way for you to
have seen all of the ship in the limited
time that you have been on it so it
stands the past that is areas in the
ship that will unlock for you to see
that you can do other raid content I
understand it in theory if they're right
execution execution with a vex DLC
inspired in our Syrus room we go get
into no we don't understand is one how
are is the facts game you know I talked
to Lord demon you know he he he's trying
to stay optimistic and I get with him
but I'm he's on the one end where he's
like you know we see the holes in the
ship let's see if buggies coming to
repair I've already left the ship I'm
sitting there looking on the shore see
syncs and if it doesn't I'll wait for
the next favor
it will send your Avenue get you back
over here like you know things don't
make sense I'm like you know most of
these old raids made sense to the
expansion so I'm like what's gonna
happen like am I gonna sit here and do
this this this vex of DLC raid in Calais
he's gonna hit me up on the ship be like
yo I got another part that I just found
the key to you want to come check it out
I don't get this it allows them to put
out raid content quicker yeah so so for
in that regard I understand it um
look here's the thing like people say oh
it has nothing to do this bro but I mean
you know best any to for the amazing
lore come on I do I do it got better
though it got better but I mean it's
it's it's like it yeah it did get better
but I played destiny because nobody does
first person template like Bungie and I
get flute and it's just a fun game
here's my here's my thing okay let's say
that you know first off they said that
this rate layer quote-unquote I'm gonna
say that every damn time you know they
say that this is going to be shorter
than the Leviathan me for one did not
think the Leviathan was very that long
so you telling me that it's gonna be
shorter I'm already picturing a appeal
of race like that's how bad I'm looking
at this right now in I want this to be
fire dude I want this to complete I want
them to shut me up but here in the past
six months they had done nothing like
that but I mean destiny 2 came out in
the variant of urge September came out
September so I said so three months past
I don't think I didn't even expect
another raid that soon so I liked it
because that I did I did cuz crota came
out the exact same time you know I mean
but I mean Chronos I mean you know crota
was short as well it was something
different not the same damn thing
it was something
let's go crota was different but one we
haven't played the new red for the rain
layer we don't know it doesn't matter we
help no sure but it's a whole other part
of the ship oh the other part of the
boat the glass is open so let's touch it
first so put put put my theme all I mean
I mean I mean this is like saying hey
you know I don't want I don't want
chicken marsala for dinner night why you
never had it I don't care it sucks this
is kind of general gamer attitude
anymore this is the same people who just
told me that people need to spike their
opinion and make sure stuff like this
doesn't happen something before you've
even tried it play it and if and if it
sucks I will be the first person put
more time into destiny we know it's not
about exactly what he's saying what he's
saying is that oh I'm sorry
but there is no first off the way that
they are even describing this is a great
activity it's already but I also have to
do a little negative in a sense that
let's give it a chance then once we get
it in our hands we put it to its paces
and we'll see if we are being finessed
affectionately yeah I mean there's no
you know you're not giving it a chance I
mean there are strikes right now in this
right playlist and I hope they give us
reasons to replay those strikes you know
strike specific Luke come on where is it
yeah where is the beginning I'm giving
it back you beasts the spectacle of
where you can be that's it that's a
third hour
it'd be different if they haven't gave
me stuff to make me not think this is
but first off they said it's been
shorter than the initial Leviathan rate
Leviathan ray was five rooms
okay second they said that it's a rate
activity which is something which is a
phrase that they have never said an
entire desk which they had to get
clarification because I just weird wall
when they use ran clinic in the same
location as the is the initial launch
raid which that's a red flag it's a red
flag suppose supposedly the environment
is going to be completely different
would expect going into the vowel the
ship it look it look different than the
golden [ __ ] that's upstairs you know
what I'm saying is it's the same
location we should not be on the
Leviathan again so soon can we go to the
dreadnought what can't we go anywhere
else besides the hold on a minute you
just criticized wait hold on a minute
I'm trying to criticize destiny for
having a relocation in a different part
of the same raid and then you're like
let's go back to the dread-nots I we
just left I'd rather go back to the
dreadknots in the place that we
literally just left okay you know okay I
mean I don't know and just III my
mentality as always you know what I'm
willing to give it a shot
in the same place for a whole okay I
understand your criticism okay I did say
now I'm going to try because I'm gonna
try it I didn't put into the into this
game not to try what I'm saying is I
would be okay if we went to Leviathan
one time in these expansions but not
we're going to the Leviathan two more
times I like the concept it's a huge
huge huge ship it eats worlds I mean for
all you know we can be on a vex world
that it ate problem is is they're not
really being that that clear first don't
they
state raid layer like they don't know
I'm serious like they said raid layer
like like it's it's a section in the
rain like a domestic messaging in the
wording I told I hear what you getting I
hear both sides
wet wet why don't we wait to see was
wait till we see you says and then let's
get a chance let's put it through its
own more weeks fellas couple more weeks
there won't be an expansion to get you
ready for fire ass how like hotel that's
across the street we should go
downstairs to the next room and all that
dope would kick has yes being a black
Friday has become this fantastic holiday
should now because I've noticed in the
purchasing trends right and if a game
falls in that three week out from Black
Friday it's turned into hey let's wait
until Black Friday so we can get the
game cheaper I'm guilty of this certain
games that fell through the cracks that
I said always to Black Friday in again
that was starting in September because I
know it definitely was buying destiny in
certain games that you hear mark that
you're gonna pick up and Black Friday
has been come the game is holiday and my
question is should companies now market
their games after Black Friday to
capitalize on the full prices of the
games because I've noticed a lot of new
games are selling for half price if more
than half price and is it cutting into
the budget of games that they are forced
to supplement that with loot crate's
if a game is a game that just came out
if a game that just came out is getting
has its price slash can happen by
further that means the game did not sell
well yeah I feel like I feel like that's
not always the case
shopping on Black Friday yeah but III
don't feel like just because a game is
on so on the biggest year I mean let's
say that you know you your gang sells
phenomenal and you know you don't want
to drop that price but you still want to
sell on Black Friday but your
competitors this half off what you gonna
do you're just gonna take that out
because you're gonna be a mom you can't
compete because your game is twice is
everything else yes I mean Wolfenstein 2
just came out and it's an it's already
half off a permanent drop in a Cell I
don't know so I don't think that's a big
deal I don't know I I a price drop that
I mean there's a reason for example the
switch did not have a price I mean the
core concept is the same like right like
like the switch doesn't have a price
it's $2.99 and it's flying off the
shelves it doesn't need it because it's
selling um the pay consequently the ps4
and the Xbox one has got price cuts
because they need them these consoles
been on the market for years now that is
how you get people to buy them the Xbox
one X did not have a price cut it's
still 40 not $4.99 on Black Friday it
doesn't need one it's selling it just
came out I thought of the main reason
they do this is competition is like I
said you can't have Wolfenstein $30 and
you know I mean obviously this is the
same developer you know you have a
what's that company uh what's the other
game besides Wolfenstein that Bethesda
just really into they've looked into 460
you know people regardless that they
came in there for the Wolfenstein
they're gonna look at that even with
them to be like maybe I could just pick
this up cuz
I am interested in this game but maybe I
could wait on Wolfenstein yeah I mean
here's the thing it's a mixture it's
both you absolutely have competitive
sales going on because shadow of war was
dropped to $35 that's a pretty big drop
and shadow of war murdered pretty much
everything else apart from maybe Mario
an assassin gathered it completely
obliterated shadow of mordor's sales
record which sidenote means it's the
first game to buck the sequel to a new
IP this gen does poor it's actually the
first one to buck that trend which is an
interesting anecdote but anyways so that
sales drop was clearly that discount was
clearly meant to encourage more people
to pick it up because other games are
getting discounted but Wolfenstein 2
evil within to pray that's a disturbing
amount that those two titles which is
disappointing but whatever I am under no
delusion those games are getting
discounted because they didn't sell
quite as well as they should
it's like I said it's not the case to
everything there are games that they're
gonna put on so there's no denying that
when you know Dead Rising came out in
December and by January it was like 40
bucks a game stock y-you know I wonder I
knew an issue of quick correction or
something Sam just said shadow of war
was actually the second game to do that
the first game to do that this gem was
destiny to just the month before launch
a line launch a line okay
yeah that's oh that does make sense yes
okay well me it's like I said like you
know it regardless but you know I do
want to say regardless with these
bethesda games do you know what they do
sell wise they're still phenomenal games
but that's the really don't be
publishing or making bad bad games
besides pray amen pretty stuff but is it
a conscious effort being made to hold
off for that specific gaming so-called
holiday or purchasing holiday because it
was it was a conscious effort on my part
to do that
I can't just waited while everybody paid
full price for these game
that they so-called couldn't wait for
and we had a ton of games to play up
until that point which I stayed busy
with Mario destiny and my Assassin's
Creed that I couldn't wait for and I
purchased all the games um I had a cheap
very cheap discount pricing I he was
able to go physical he even got it
cheaper kid smooth he waited on the evil
within two and a wolfenstein and the
moment that sell was he picked them both
up for 30 each
exactly you don't my favorite thing
about Black Friday in the gaming
community is here's my favorite thing my
pictures of pellets when you get on
Twitter pictures of the empty of the
empty PlayStation 4 yeah they're like
Playstations selling out baby and then
you get the same thing for the Xbox and
the same thing for the switch and then I
just love like I don't I don't as long
as they're all selling well I think care
less but I just love the disappointed
faces of whatever fanboys on Twitter and
that's that's my favorite part is is
just watching these these console
warriors go nuts over over over what
sold and and what didn't sell and that
to me is when I break up my horn and I
pour myself a little bourbon and I sit
down sit in front of Twitter and I just
soak it all in a story on that padlet
stuff I paid my uncle he worked at
Walmart for a while and I remember I
went out there to pick him up it was a
you know steering he got off before
Thanksgiving for some before the Black
Friday it was like probably hour into it
he had something going on he had to get
off and they literally just unloaded a
pallet onto another one so obviously
they put the the reserve stock on the
the main you know the main display and I
saw people taking pictures of the thing
they just wrote out this to switch
they're like Oh doubt and I'm like dude
they literally just brought that out
here to switch it yeah honestly like
that then what I love about that I mean
Black Friday brings out the absolute
worst and
in the console warriors yeah brings out
or maybe it brings out the best I don't
know because it's so incredibly
entertaining but honestly like you can
take that you could take that and bring
it all the way back to net neutrality
and say you guys are pouring all this
energy into this meaningless in console
war that you have invented that by the
way these executives do not fight they
do not care about this take all that
energy and all that hatred and put and
unite yourselves and pour it into
something like net neutrality um you
know it's dead about that don't get
upset about PlayStation for not selling
as well as Xbox or switch not selling as
well as ps4 don't get upset about that
get upset about something like net
neutrality because you know what at the
end of the day we are all there's no
playstation community
there's no Xbox community there's no
switch community there's a gaming
community and it's something like and if
this hobby were to go away tomorrow we
would all lose out equally so why can't
we just you know I was there last time
you went away it's like I said last
night on the podcast I did bail on
brother man hey you know the next time
you think that you know there's a side
or a green side or a blue side or I
don't necessarily know what side
Nintendo would be colored would be but I
read yeah right so you have these sides
it regards what it is like
gamers came together made a
multi-million dollar corporation bow to
us and then not only that we made a
multi-billion dollar corporation tell
multi-million dollar corporation that
this needs to change yeah it's just a I
mean when you talk Black Friday you know
like I mean nobody's gonna know what's
sold more until we get don't we get the
MPD's or until we hear a statement which
we usually do saying you know you know
okay what we saw and by the way I want
to point out just because just because
one console sells the most on Black
Friday does not mean it sells the most
for the month by a long shot so you know
honestly that stock was a little yeah
exactly I'm Mike Mike my bed is that the
switch probably pulled it out but which
would be incredible considering it did
not get a price coming that would be I
mean wouldn't that be insane if there's
that way
crazy which did not get a price cut
actually sold more than we're hoping we
don't have like on and talked on this
podcast where we're hoping Matt sir
that would be like look as long as
everything selling whoa I don't care oh
we just have a Ben Denis segment here I
would I would love to see the shocked
faces of people we did not see that
coming I just that you'll be seeing it
for me I just a commercial for a jewelry
store guys who were planning to propose
this holiday ring with your xbox one I
will say that I will say this like this
is about as deep end of the stuff is not
yet this is I do feel like this is a
very critical holiday period for
Microsoft if the X bar is so so you just
think the Xbox one X come out I don't
think it's gonna move the needle the way
people say I think it'll sell more to
the Xbox core than the ps4 Pro did to
the ps4 crook or simply because I feel
like there was more excitement in that
sub-sect of gamers um for the X but if
Microsoft
after releasing this new very powerful
console if they have a poor showing in
November which I don't think I don't
think they will but if they do where do
they go from there
well you know as the games you know you
say that like when this generation
started I did not think exclusives
mattered all that much anymore after the
first year I was like exclusives or not
but now I don't know if I I don't know
if that's true or not anymore that Matt
piscatella was saying that that was the
case in the beginning of the generation
and that it then had changed like year I
think two three whatever in this
consul-general were a correlation
between who's coming out and pushing
console sales from I think III think you
said the big change happened one this
which came out because let's face it
nobody is buying the switch for
third-party games you're buying to
switch for first party games and
Nintendo probably has the strongest most
recognizable stable of first party games
in the business um and the switch is
murdering it this year it's a complete
180 from the Wii U so so maybe
exclusives maybe they matter more than I
thought they did and maybe that's why
maybe that's why PlayStation 4 is is
just outpacing the Xbox um I I don't
know but I do know that I really hope
Microsoft is a strong showing on does
not just not Black Friday but for
November in general because I think that
is a I think that that is that will be
that will be a statement on on the state
of that console in the industry having
just had a new console come out and they
poured I feel like a lot more
advertising into the X 10 ps4 did to the
pro they they had to yeah I mean I mean
Sony could afford with getting wet and
and let's face it like the reveal the
pro was a snoozer like I was like
anybody I like mercury but we're live
streaming that thing was like I was like
what is this
meanwhile at the end you know yeah some
of the marketing languages go through
perfect pixels I don't know
you know at the same time at work you
know it got people hacked up yeah and so
I feel I feel like if Microsoft comes in
third in November that's that that's a
bad look yeah that's that's something to
be very concerned about now that they
also was going on is these a Playstation
sailu be no Black Friday it doesn't
represent the whole month no from my
understanding like what they dropped to
about 189 Brad that Sony they they have
like some no the xbox slim was one
eighty nine but I mean I mmm this is the
numbers visually gives you a feeling
like if you see one 89 opposed to one
ninety nine it's a feeling that your
brain yeah now apparently the the
apparent of the ps4 has been is sold out
everywhere now which is ridiculous if
that's true for a four-year-old council
I mean that's insane I just I have a
feeling that the Xbox is going to be
trailing the ps4 in the switch in
November and I'm sure people will take
that as saying John is a fanboy like
that I want the Xbox one to sell I would
love to see it saw more than anything
else November because I would love these
three competitive consoles as well you
know he doesn't have an Xbox you know I
mean I played on a ps3 and an Xbox 360
equally last gen because I had more time
I wasn't married alright you know but
for the I mean further for the current
gen I mean I got a ps4 I got a ps4
because most of my friends ended up
getting a ps4 and go your friends on it
would not make sense for me to switch
over to an Xbox now at this point
because all my I mean I've got so many
trophies on ps4 network now that's
exactly what I say I say you play with
your friends you play with your stack is
the achievements are this stuff means
things to people it means something
the ecosystem is important like the
ecosystem that you're on cop you're
comfortable with and where your friends
are ultimately is gonna help decide
where you're gonna actually game so I
definitely hear it I mean it's gonna be
interested this whole Black Friday thing
is just pretty entertainment right now
who's not part of the bendi segment
because it's not too late to join I'm
gonna be too did SDG see where they got
mats could tell are we that that episode
is gonna be so mad pista Katella who's
the MPD analyst he comes on every month
he's an unofficial member of the podcast
and he comes on every month to talk
about and be and by the way if you've
never seen him talk he is extremely
knowledgeable about the industry it is
fascinating so you go with the switch I
take it or I personally you know what
you know what II try to get up and
commit I'm waffling between the ps4 I
still yeah I still think this which is
going to take it all right we got your
name on the switch I think I think yeah
I think that I mean if you love me yeah
[Laughter]
we don't really have a lot of evidence
per se we have a lot of anecdotes we
have a lot of anecdotes I'll say it
again so it's it's extremely difficult
to say honestly you could put these
three Xbox Playstation switch them any
order and I believe it I would believe
any order I believe any call way just
good fun we've been doing this thing
called baby if you if you have to force
me a good fun in here then it would be
something like get on your knees so Xbox
switch PlayStation just to shake things
up
oh I really need to emphasize the fact I
can believe anything happening oh look
at that he voted for the winning team
we're gonna have all the people last
guests that we've encouraged Lord
rappers been part of it you know as far
as who our predictions are who we think
will win just a little fun segment like
I said once that the winner is announced
you know we'll just have either you guys
either come into the live chat just
hashtag bend the knee and retweet for
some good like I said it's like long-
said it's one of these unique situations
where all with a big three are in prime
position
they've all got great arguments they're
selling well you know the ex is doing
well in tennis which has been a
phenomenal PlayStation has been the
dominating force of the generation so
it's just fun to see you know the more
compete and this is what you really
can't definitively say it's interesting
it's interesting when you look at how
well all the consoles and everything is
selling well right now maybe all those
articles back in 2012 saying gaming
mobile had taken over it's done around
the same time you had a bunch of
articles from publications no Wes
talking about how MOBAs were the future
and that's that's where all games needed
to go and things like that so anytime
something says blank is the future raise
an eyebrow notice how I got that same
answer you were looking for with the bet
to your bad this is a little kick I just
want to point out real quick to my
fellow Lords here that I actually got to
drop I've got a hard stop time hilarious
12:45 and I'm so sorry I'm sorry at all
not at all Dustin stuff but uh you know
it was mentioned earlier when you guys
were doing that amazing introduction
that I do I do voices so I figured
henrique knows I figured I could do like
a little Christopher Walken before I
just go ahead do your outros because I
think we're about to know like what if
Kratos was was Chris played by
Christopher Walken right give me I can
do this out laughing so forgive me but
you know what it's like Zeus
yes has returned I bring with me through
huge fan and sddc shout out your team
everybody over there and like I said
laughs gotta hit you back on what's a
gig and like I said I'm an absolute
pleasure man ya know I do it was a lot
of fun talking to you guys
it's I'll come back on whatever you want
um please if you have not subscribed to
the iron Lords podcast and you listen to
this do it these are a bunch of good
guys um and I'll go ahead and tell you
to subscribe to our own channel super
forum games cast which goes live every
Thursday night at 9 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
yes sir Duke super-deformed games cast
and we are gonna be doing our game of
the year show soon very soon and anybody
who watches this knows what a hot mess
that's gonna be interesting our top 100
games of all time was whoa that was bad
we always have a good time we're usually
a few drinks in when we go live so it's
always fun there's a lot of yelling and
we have a motto it's it's it's not
always poetry and we don't always agree
but we always keep it real and that
pretty much sums up the pretty much sums
up the podcast but anyway I got a drop
guys it was a pleasure and an honor
being on Enrique and Sam you guys are my
boys you guys know that and it does if
you guys have not checked out basement
radio arcade podcast which is sister
podcast or real games media I highly
suggest you guys go and subscribe to
that absolutely so anyway guys have a
good rest of your weekend
and everybody out in the gaming
community please be kind to each other
absolutely love negative be safe thank
you guys see cool cool so yeah be was
gonna get close to wrapping this thing
up unless uh Lord addict I know he
wanted to talk a little uh we say switch
dodo so is absolute pleasure Lord Sam
and of course Lord brat drop and do so
Lord Sam wick and the fine people find
you so you can find and follow me on
Twitter if you want to hear what I have
to say you may not like it you have been
warned you can find
I keep my thoughts brief but I pull no
punches so it is what it is
all right things honest I'm happy to
talk to anyone whenever I can you know I
mean you might send me a message I might
be in class too working on something but
I'll happily get back with anyone who
wants to talk or just chat about games
or movies or whatever that's at Samuel
Tolbert very very easy fine and then
when I'm not on Twitter you can find me
at real game Mediacom true and I will be
writing reviews opinion pieces articles
and if I'm not it's because I'm looking
something up to work on something else
new or I'm actually doing the most
important thing and that is playing
games that's right outright no that's
what it's about very appreciate you let
us say a long-overdue huge fan got a
chance to meet you finally and all like
I said always shout shout out the on
team because you guys do good work
appreciate it thank you we appreciate
the support we really do you guys are
awesome thank you so much so hard rap
with the mystery challenge of period
talk about it I was like oh I need to
talk about this I know I had was very
very powerful it actually brought me up
to speed and understanding the nuances
that I didn't understand yeah absolutely
sure man thank you yeah absolutely we
can find people find you yeah you can
follow me on Twitter at braaap
underscore podcast mmm and you know we
actually are in the midst of running a
holiday competition right now yeah we're
giving away free PlayStation 4 console
compliments of mr. chicken spaghetti by
the way who's a great community member
he actually picked us and a few other
podcasts to do his uh his holiday
giveaway so big shout out to em and I'm
also uh I'm also gonna be part of
another podcast that's gonna be coming
out December 3rd Looch s radio with us
really yeah with Jay Fonzarelli Oh
saltiest gamer oh yes my guy so who is
it it's so fun really you all day
digital yep nice not popular we in the
early stages we cooking well you have
the first podcast it's not gonna be a
live podcast we're gonna record it but
it will drop December 3rd so um yeah
just keep an eye out for that you can
follow you could follow loot chests
radio at at loot chests radio on Twitter
so definitely give us a follow and yeah
we just you know just gonna get together
and talk about no games and you know
video game news and our opinions on
things with the industry and you know
we're gonna be focusing on getting some
more industry guests onto so another
straight game talk you know we respect
it no doubt before we outro with the law
it's just real quick the new ILP poll
this week will be going up probably
tomorrow so it's pretty much no we don't
get to do out of the Lord the Lord's
gets saved for last
[Laughter]
I got my brother but uh pepole be with
the rise of social media Twitter reddit
etc bringing more attention to gaming
industry practices and giving more
direct access to execs the question is
is this good for gaming as a whole a yes
shines light on bad practices and
corrupt individuals be no issues are
overblown and way too many personal
attacks or see I don't care I just want
to get my game on the poor dad get my C
from last week
you got your c4 blast you see did not
win they were very shallow d than that
we lasted that with
the question does it take Rock the Vote
and now we're gonna do our fish out
rolls for the Lord's my brother from
another mother the howl of the young
wolf very energetic pre Benadryl the
roll I freaking love this we could have
found people find you what you got
cooking up first off I want to go ahead
and make a public announcement that uh
King be acting like I've missed every
part saying that I'm saying the energy
level I love it please don't take this
as a negative or dig at me trying to get
at you I really love your energy because
when you come with high energy please
let's keep it rolling
that desk D segment was intense I was
like I definitely want to you know thank
all our guests for coming out here
you know I dropped I dropped the other
podcast definitely go check that out
here's brats podcast go check that out
in the in the comments the chat uh hey
as it far as me you know I don't know if
I'll be on Planet Xbox Wednesday I'm
still having you know in the middle of
my my you know personal issues but I
definitely want to thank everyone for
coming out I'm not gonna be able to stay
to the very end the podcast so I have to
go out my out right now my brother just
showed up okay I do appreciate everyone
that showed up low Cardini you take a I
got you bro you already know that's my
guy and of course shout the loss saw who
could not make it you know I'm saying
but death and came through with that
cameo courtesy of Lord King on the
feature and Lord King we're gonna find
people find you I want you guys really
to add me on xbox okay um but also send
me a message and say podcast just you
know just a message pocket King David
OTW
alright um I want to give a shout out to
everybody that went out this Black
Friday and maximized their Xbox 1x
experience and even those people that
didn't go out and maximize the Xbox 1x
experience they maximize it by
purchasing the Xbox one X you supported
the gaming community
um Eric J shout-out to Lord Eric J he
went out he porch it purchased his 4k
television - he's maximizing situation
as well I mean it means a lot you have
to understand when it's coming from the
vision standpoint when you purchase for
your systems and you see what your
system is fully capable of I'm sure Lord
brat can attest to this when he put that
4k HDR on he sat back and said wow and I
know what King is talking about I
literally was walking around trying to
get different angles of the Sun ooh I
mean seriously I was like I was on I was
at a party chat with all day and and
Fonzarelli last night and I wasn't even
I wasn't even doing any missions I was
walking around trying to get different
angles of the Sun to see the lighting
effects in the shadows mmm it was just
yeah it was it was it was nice it was
nice yeah 4k resolution and I knew you
weren't because I know you like the
premium gaming experience every guest
that showed up today even family that
showed up as in an Enrique Brett Lord
breath um but when I when I listen I got
to tell you guys a secret um when I
jumped in a live chat you know because
we have the video feed and I looked at
Lord Megatron and I'm like this dude
looks like a Deadpool I thought I was
sleeping still I said I overslept the
podcast overslept the black ass shut out
it was just a really funny moment for
myself
Oh
if we got that going
it's my guy right Alerus rare form good
dude
great topic Cena yeah thanks everybody
coming to chat was lit today
much appreciated again or negative brat
Lord Samuel tobert in the building the
direwolf the Galt Rivia himself absolute
pleasure because everyone you guys get
that like surprise subscribe like I said
all the ILP on the inner circle Network
the media outlets YouTube iTunes Google
Play all that stuff will be going up
later the audio aspect and of course the
amazing tech GN patreon that links in
the description all the help from the
Lord is greatly appreciated you have
another glorious Sunday in the books and
we're gonna end this thing on and on
that note peace peace